You know we have to tear down this really
animosity that the jihadist movement has against
America.
There's people who hate america.
And I have found the best way to treat this
severe hatred is build up a counter force.
And that's through women and children and
using medical diplomacy.
I've traveled all over the world and I'm blessed
by it.
An I've had the opportunity as Secretary of
Health to see there is one common denominator,
whether you're a Shiite, Suuni, Kurd, Hamas,
Hezbola, Jewish member, everything revolves
around how you're going to provide good health,
good security, but good health for the family.
And this is with women and children.
And if you're really able to tap into that,
you're going to be able to start a movement
across the world.
It's going to be basing themselves on good
health conditions, good health for their family.
And that's what I want to do through global
medical diplomacy.
I've got a plan laid out, really to develop
that.
And I think that's the kind of ideas and positive
things we have to do in this country to show
the world that we're not this terrible country
that's trying to invade and be able to in
any way change their way of life.
We got to show them that this is America.
That we're good.
We're positive.
We're strong, and we want to protect you,
and we want to do what is right.